this is a production of Cornell
University
sure Thank You Rochelle so good
afternoon everyone
today we have we have to research about
breeding for disease resistant but let's
start with my non edible switchgrass
first so my research my research is to
improve switchgrass population to be
resistant to diseases cost / furs
alrighty and today I would like to
introduce you what is switchgrass
because I don't think many of you know
where's about switchgrass how many of
you know switchgrass like literally
touch through scratch before it's pretty
each evil and and I'm going to am going
to tell you about background of the
disease that I'm working on the progress
of the selections of those diseases and
the correlation between the the
resistant of two diseases so this is me
with switchgrass and subscribe it's
pretty new newly domesticated crop it
was just domestic domesticated there's
only less than a hundred years ago so we
still have like lots of diversity in in
switchgrass and it was only about like
one decade ago that we use it for the
Department of Energy has selected
switchgrass as a biomass energy crop
so basically switchgrass was just grown
to like proposed to be the plan for
producing electricity like and also can
convert it to ethanol in the future in
the wind that when the gas ride is
pretty high not not this time but maybe
in the near future and you may think
that hey in these pictures like this
which has even like smaller than me and
like not that good in terms of the year
in this picture but but in this picture
it was taken in a Ralph Penn State
University and this area is proposing to
be an ideal area for planting
switchgrass
because it's a marginal land which means
that no other crop can make any play any
the good new based on this in this land
like in this in this area is a my
claimed area which means that like
nobody cares about that land and
switchgrass was pushed through planted
in that low my
no machi Nolan so and most of the
research that has been done in
switchgrass it's focusing on increasing
the you and other agronomic traits but
very few that's only couples of research
has been proposed about the disease
resistant in the switchgrass even though
the one of the disease that can reduce
the year up to 50% of biomass which is a
whole world of subscribe if you can if
you reduce the biomass of true scratch
like switchgrass is nothing for you so
these diseases caused by vipers or
actually help is significant not only
poor in the you reduction but also it
can reduce the germination which
switchgrass is a perennial crop so the
first year establishment it's very
important for switchgrass if it can
reduce the termination which means that
if we do so by our method you can get
for many years also so in my breeding
program I'm working with up to a plan
switchgrass shelter and cabin block and
based on that to diseases bikers or
vibrate leaf spot and by free to the
feedlot I separate into I separate them
into like two distinct paths distinct
breeding program and I'll reach done
than the true cycle of selection based
on those traits and I'm going to
continue the third cycle of selection
based on by for a seat dots and usually
why I'm keep continuing this and on
based on the second cycle of selection I
chase the reciprocal chase to see the
correlation between the trade so let's
move to the first resistant the
resistant to Vipers a leaf spot
basically Isis sprayed inoculum on the
forward for seedlings and cover with a
clear plastic bag for 24 hours release
it and leave it for 270 day servant
daily and evaluate the disease based on
the percentage of percent lesions on the
leaf and because the base species has
very few studies in previously so I
didn't know like this depict that
control background that control this
threat before so before you jump in in
general before you jump in for breeding
anything you should have
a background of these how is this is
irritable so I wanted to calculate the
first ability before I made any
selection so I could use a half succeeds
of the lowland types of Kelo in
greenhouse because I cannot produce the
secant of view in if it's too cold and I
produce a half succeeds of the cello and
shelter in the field and and surrounded
by surrounding them virus welcome to
them to produce to read to prevent the
cross correlation between the plot but
sadly the her ability aren't based on
this resistant to bivariate leaf lot
it's significantly like non significant
or zero which means that I may not
expect any gain from selection on this
but I still hope that okay after two
cycle of selection I should get some
gain of this selection but sadly if I
didn't get any gains from the selections
from from this to like two years of
psycho selection so the y-axis is
percent disability the the higher the
bar the most acceptable it is so the
lower the more resistant but across the
psycho zero one two here
there's no like significantly
improvement on this so I didn't get any
significant gain from that or like
significant realize irritability which
mean that I like the 50% of my PhD term
that has already devoted to this hats
like nothing so I so I stepped back and
I didn't cry but I stepped back and like
try to look at the bigger pictures like
okay I'm is like things like to narrow
to this like few cultivars that I tasted
only like couple cultivar
so last year I had a chance to access to
the Association panel which is a which
consists of five hundred and nine Jewish
quarter has been genotypes already and
it was transplanted in in Ithaca last
year so I have the chance to to went to
the field and do a few evaluations this
rough roughly and as it shows in the
segregation then an effort and we
like some variation in in the lowland
type and a plant type switchgrass so
based on this result I really hope I get
significant peep from genome-wide
Association analysis but again no
significant feed from this even though
the QQ plot shows it like shows no
significant at the end here like so so I
would try my last year of my PhD now
focus in this somewhere to try to
phenotype this trade again by now like
the detach the leaf from the field and
put it back in the green in the lab and
spread it evaluate the disease later so
I have five minutes with less moving on
to something something impressive I have
another disease resistant and do you
remember the disease resistant to by
forests it brought which basically I
didn't expect much about this so best
because I just softest the seat in the
interest water and queen as a control
compared with the the seats with the
treatment which is a
inoculum and based on that I collected
the data based on two minutes or not
zero and one so based on that comparison
I can also calculate the percent
termination reduction which I can turns
out that I can calculate hurts ability
based on hopsie however the way I make a
selection I make only like selection
based on individual fan shot if
germinate from the treatment one so I
need to find a way to calculate the
half-hertz ability based on individual
selection and I found a way to fit the
model in binomial model and luckily I
get pretty impressive like moderate to
high heritability based on how quick
selection went from point six eight two
point nine in each different cultivars
and let's focus on the individual
selection here that I get in cable of
the Omega selection
I had the point three for its ability
and which is which is also significant
fertility so I really have my last hope
in my ph.d program that it may work and
it and this result is showing the
progress of my selection the x-axis its
percent domination
and each pairs of the of the bar
representing each cycle of selection on
your left hand side
it's a Cuban drop and your right hand
side in the shelter so let's focus on
the parental line parental generation
the cycle zero you will see that the
blue bar which is a control one has high
significantly higher germination than
the red bar which is a percent
diminution of the treatment one which is
consistent with a shelter here also
there's significantly different
however with it within only one cycle of
selection I can reduce that gap between
the blue bar and red bar to non
significantly different and based on
that and based on this gap between the
blue barn red bar I plot the next graph
which y-axis represents the percent
termination reduction however I didn't
see I didn't see any progress
significant progress in heaven drops
from cycle zero one and two but you see
that the trail is reducing which means
it's more resistant to the disease when
we consider the shelter one from the non
the parent role I the reduction percent
reduction is pretty high but only one
cycle of selection it totally we reduced
that that one to two improve that a lot
so based on that I calculate I can I get
significant gain from from from this
trade up to like 100 percent like in one
cycle of the election which I need to
repeat that
I already repeat a couple times but I
need to repeat it again but it's pretty
impressive
only one cycle of selection can do that
and I would I wanted to compare with my
individual base rate ability but because
of the the trader is only zero and one I
cannot I cannot calculate the real life
heritability that's on that so I found a
way to calculate the liability validity
and you see here at point four it's
pretty close to quite through the egg
calculate earlier which means that okay
I got pretty like consistent results
from this selection and and now let's
compare these two resistant as soon as I
presented to you earlier I D
any impressive great game from resistant
to new spotlights our flat here but you
see the trend in recent to Citrix here
it's some improvement here some
improvement here which and so based on
this data I can calculate the
correlation between the resistant and as
a graphic yes there's no correlation
it's non significant here which I which
can explain that the mechanism behind
the resistant are different which make
sense rather the resistant increase and
resistant in seedlings a different stage
so which is has no correlation
so in summary due to the low and non
significant for the resistant to vibrate
leaf spot I didn't get any gain and from
selection and this year I'm going to try
the fewest analysis I get like improving
my phenotyping in the field again and I
hope I could come up with some mechanism
behind that some significant things
behind that and based on moderate to
high fertility of the resistant to
vibrate state law did what I get pretty
in although I didn't have like a
significant gauge in Kevin rock but I I
get pretty impressive significant gain
in shelter and we I'll continue the
selection of the third cycle again based
on the different trends in this
resistant I we get like month
significant correlation between these
two traits so thank you for autumn ila
and thank you for your attention where
we welcome for any questions or
suggestions
[Applause]
yeah so I calculate the brats and her
activities and even the button is only
23 for that so I need em and because
luckily it was not a good representative
year because it's a it's pretty dry and
it's not a like it's not good for my
disease to occur in the field and also
the plan was so small you were just
transplant it so it's like b-sides and
compared to like this side of
switchgrass that it should be so yeah
what would slightly so it's rendered
from a pet apply to octopi and the one
that I make the selection is our octopi
so it may like have some like like
difficulty in terms of like pushing
those genetic oh I'm so this I try like
couple of them but the one that I
present that to you is useless only I by
using our block package oh the point the
point in this case is I use I try our
blob and tassel because a switchgrass
although it's octopi and that apply but
it has a diatomic stacked equation so we
can like use those like part with it yep
to come after this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu